enemies to be enemies to the West
[Music]
enemies to the south and I miss to the
north whatever stands in our way we will
defeat it with a mallet
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will
/ - father
what is it gone yet here you stand
lack best help against the coming storm
if we don't put aside our enmities and
bound together we will die and then it
doesn't matter whose skeleton sits on
the Iron Throne
[Music]
[Music]
the Great Wall is here
hey guys pts and there it is the first
official trailer for season 7 with
actual footage and it's pretty exciting
now the disclaimer is capped at midnight
in my part of the world so I'm going to
give a quick breakdown and see what we
have so it opens up with the Lannisters
so we'll talk about them first so we see
her Majesty the Queen Cersei first of
her name coming out and looking over
what we find out later is her brand new
map room which is pretty cool she has a
little monologue there and she talks
about how there's enemies closing in on
all sides but they're gonna have to take
them out and we see Jaime by her side
who seems to be along for the ride at
least at this point and Circe's made her
intentions quite clear she wants to
destroy everybody because they're the
last Lannisters or at least the last
ones that count now we do get a little
bit of Tyrion in this and we see him
he's in a field overlooking what I am
not exactly short honestly I assume that
he's in the region of Dragonstone or
he's looking towards Westeros from
somewhere outside but we also see drogon
flyby which is a first glimpse of him in
full motion we also see quite a bit of
Lannister soldiers engaged in combat we
see them fighting the Dothraki and we
see them with a nice shot of grey worm
plating some Lannister's now none of
this looks to be in King's Landing as
far as I can tell and everything that
we've gotten so far says that it should
be at Highgarden which we're presuming
that they will sack but at the same time
you know there is where they engaged
with the Dothraki and everything like
that well that would be on the way back
afterwards we also got some footage of
REO we've already seen a couple of
pictures of her on horseback but she
seems to be headed north as we assumed
she would be I don't see anything in
this trailer that was indicate that she
stays in the Riverlands but that doesn't
mean that she bawled at least at the
beginning mostly she's wandering around
starting a fire in this one shot and
then we see her looking under a bed
which could be just about anywhere at
this point yet Theon and we get him in
this burning
scene which is tied to this burning ship
I would imagine and we also see someone
jump overboard during that same battle
which again I think we'll probably be
see on most likely this is the sea
battle the big battle at sea between
Iran and Theon and Yara Greyjoy who
joined up with Danny now we think that
Dany will probably split her forces and
these guys will run into Euron and
history Davos does a little bit of
narration and he's talking to what I
would guess would be Cersei explaining
that you know none of this matters
because the White Walkers are coming and
everyone has to band together so we
figured that Davos is probably trying to
get King's Landing on board with going
to war up north now the big thing for a
lot of people will be that we see
Daenerys arrives at Dragonstone we see
her touchdown we see her touch the sand
and she gives us some some speech about
how she was born to rule this place and
we see her opening the gates at
Dragonstone we see her on her brand-new
throne there and after all this time we
see her arrived we also see her Dothraki
riding into battle and we like I said we
do see quite a bit of the unsullied in
this clip not to be outdone by the
people on the South King in the north
Jon Snow is also featured pretty heavily
here we see him in the Great Hall at
Winterfell and then we see something
pretty interesting here we see him what
looks like the crypts and he's down
there with Littlefinger and he pretty
much throttles Littlefinger he grabs him
up and looks like he's threatening him
but we can't hear what they're saying
obviously now the positioning of this is
interesting to me because Littlefinger
could possibly know something about
Jon's heritage and where they're at
could be near where the statue of his
mother is so that's something to keep in
mind for later I can't say for sure we
also get some other little finger stuff
where he's kind of lurking in the
background and the Great Hall or
somewhere and we also see him
in that scene we've seen several times
with Sansa but he's basically trying to
do what would you would think he would
try to do he's trying to turn her
against her family some other notable
things we see in the background shots we
see grey worm getting it on with Miss
Andy we heard some rumors about that and
we see her she's kind of taking his
clothes off and yeah and we also see
Yara Greyjoy and Illyria sands making
out which I'm not sure where in the
timeline that fits it could be on the
ship before the battle or it could be
some time afterwards but we're not
really know what no way to tell there we
see the mountain in the new Kings guard
armor that Cersei has in place he looks
pretty badass we also get a status
update on jor-el's greyscale which looks
pretty bad at this point he's sort of
locked away there probably at the
Citadel I would guess but you know we
don't know for sure we also see Jon
running around in the north we get a
little bit of torment and then I say to
the north I mean the far north
perhaps north of the wall and probably
the stuff we saw they were shooting it
will fill quarry which would be a
showdown where they're trying to capture
the white we sort of see them running
and then we see them circling up in the
heavy snow so things aren't going their
way as far as we can tell I don't know
it's pretty cool all the way around
there's a lot of stuff and I'm sure
there's some stuff I might have missed
it there's a scene here where there's a
hand and it's toppling the Lannister
lion thank that's Tyrion tan if you look
at the position of the shoulder it looks
like he's loaded ground there and I'm
trying to think what is my favorite
thing that we see here I really don't
know it's all pretty cool I think that I
have been excited for this battle at sea
I think it'll look awesome so it's kind
of cool to see that we see the ship
coming in and then we see it on fire oh
yeah and this I mean I did not know if
we would see Melisandre and we actually
get a shot of her now it looks like
she's hiding out nearby Dragonstone
watching things unfold what does it all
mean I have no
is she is she invited is she just
sneaking up seeing what's going on is
she following John from afar or she
looking for Daenerys we really don't
have much info on this and that's
exciting to me the other thing is is
that what's she going to do whenever she
gets there I mean both of these people
are obvious candidates for her prophecy
so who knows what's going to happen
whenever that hat you know maybe she's
not even going to really get involved I
hope she does those this is probably one
of the most exciting things for me also
even though I'm not the biggest Daenerys
fan boy I do really like seeing her come
home at Dragonstone there's that shot
where her and Tyrion are looking over
the map table there and and that's
pretty awesome
it's also this quick shot of the wall
opening out then as my inner brand
fanboy comes out yeah I like this a lot
I think that's pretty cool and also all
the battle stuff you know the wolf ale
stuff looks cool the Lannisters -
Dothraki and the unsullied all throwing
down it's pretty cool I mean I'm pretty
excited about this whole thing if it
wasn't the middle of the night I would
be super super excited but let me know
what you guys think what are you what
are you most excited about and what and
what's your favorite storyline going
into this season make sure you subscribe
to my channel for all my Game of Thrones
updates and thanks for watching out talk
to you soon